guess who's here
wait breathe hey
we're at starbucks we're off to get the
sister christmas pictures but also with
little baby bow where's he at
are you holding him yeah he's sweeping
right here
well you can't ever see him and of
course we're at starbucks okay you have
the i want the window down a little
white chocolate mocha grande i wanna
granny white chocolate mocha nonfat hi
can i get that grande um non-fat white
chocolate white chocolate mocha grande
non-fat
a grande non-fat chestnut praline
chestnut praline with a pump with a pump
of vanilla
somebody knows they're getting their
picture taken look how excited he is
look how excited
running to get his picture taken
i don't think bo has any idea what he's
about to get himself into
and he has no choice
he's going to pee as soon as we get to
the photo studio
as
soon as we get there
upstairs looking at me so excited
this would be interesting
this is gonna be awful
maybe because he's in a mall
shake shake shake it hey don't need your
exams
to make sure that we don't do this right
now
stay here i'll be right
i don't think he wants to show anybody
she's pretty anything look at my pretty
scarf this is going to be
i'm not really i think it's going to be
bad just be good like that
oh here we go
come here look at him
such a good little boy so cute you're
being so good all right pick them up and
then put them back
i was
good job little bow you got your first
pictures taken good boy he's like take
me home
all right guys here's our final
christmas and thanksgiving pictures i
will uh i'll show you them right here
and look at little bow he did such a
good job today okay oh
we knew that wouldn't last too long of
course
all right guys thanks for watching hope
you guys enjoyed make sure you go follow
a bow all over the internet he's basic
bow except on twitter he's basically
tweets okay come on guys we're gonna
shoot a video